[Música]
la otra pandemia y si esta en particular
es una que a mí me ha tocado vivir desde
la primera línea y como buena periodista
que soy me gustaría comenzar con una
pregunta
usted se acuerdan que estaban haciendo
en la tarde del 31 de diciembre de 2019
me imagino que preparándose para la
fiesta de fin de año y yo les va a decir
que yo también pero además ese día me
había ofrecido a trabajar por la tarde
en la sala de redacción si acaso éramos
unas 4 o 5 personas hay en la nación y
realmente es una fecha en la que a mí me
gusta trabajar porque es tranquilo el
ambiente y además de eso difícilmente
van a aparecer informaciones muy
técnicas que a mí me obliguen a sentarme
a estudiar durante gran rato como es muy
común y poder traducir lo técnico a un
lenguaje amigable con las personas para
ayudarles a entender lo que sucede a su
alrededor en caso de ciencia oa mejorar
o mantener su salud pero bueno resulta
que si pasó en determinado momento de la
tarde entra esta información veamos la
más a detalle
este es un comunicado de la asociación
internacional de enfermedades
infecciosas
entró un cable de una agencia de
noticias informando de este comunicado
hablaba de una enfermedad no
diagnosticada en china siendo la es muy
sincera este tipo de informaciones son
comunes y es normal que se hablen de
algunos brotes de enfermedades en países
muy lejanos a los que si se les da
cierta relevancia la información se
consigna en la página de internet y
frecuentemente en impreso también y ya
tanto mi compañero de informaciones
internacionales como yo nos fuimos para
la casa a nuestras celebraciones de año
nuevo pensando en que esta fue una
información
fortuita y que no íbamos a estar esté a
las puertas de vivir una pandemia que se
vivió de forma concomitante a la coidh
si el frasco 2 virus causante de la
coidh 19 nos tienen una pandemia desde
inicios de 2020
justamente al mismo tiempo estaba
comenzando otra pandemia causada por el
virus de la desinformación que causa una
enfermedad llamada info demia y que es
igual de grave mientras médicos
enfermeros profesionales de
microbiología y en biología estaban
viendo como atendían coi 19 quienes
estamos de este lado estamos viendo cómo
atendemos la info de mya y por qué
porque también tiene características
diferentes cuando se haga el sars co2
para poder transmitirse y causar kobe 19
se hablaba en un inicio de que si no se
tomaban medidas un portador del virus
podría llevar la enfermedad a unas 34
personas
conforme fueron apareciendo variantes
más transmisibles se fueron dando y
hablando de 5 6 7 8 personas
pero qué sucede con la desinformación y
la enfermedad de infodema ya que no
necesitamos estar en un mismo espacio
físico para ser portadores de ese virus
y transmitirlo a alguien más gracias a
las formas de comunicación de este
momento yo como portadora de virus sin
saberlo puedo ser una portadora
asintomática también puedo transmitirle
el virus incluso a personas que no están
en el mismo país donde yo estoy
el primer año de la pandemia hace que
podamos tal vez predecir lo que vaya a
pasar en la post pandemia no una
predicción como tal pero si tener
ciertas señales de lo que va a suceder
después este primer año de la pandemia
nos sorprendió a todos y sorprender a la
sala de redacción sin periodistas
especializados en temas de ciencia y
salud somos pocos los periodistas en
este país que tenemos la fortuna y
bendición de podernos dedicar a un área
del conocimiento en especial y formarnos
en ella entonces a muchos nos tocó
aprender de cero y han hecho un gran
trabajo en eso y por otro lado
profesionales de la salud que no estaban
preparados para hablar con periodistas
muchos de ellos nunca lo habían hecho y
tampoco estaban preparados para hacer
ellos comunicadores y poder
hacia las masas en sus redes sociales
hablar de lo que ellos estaban
estudiando en la pandemia
qué está sucediendo
desde que comenzó la pandemia algo que
ya veníamos viendo desde antes y es que
nuestra forma de comunicación y de
informarnos de lo que sucede a nuestro
alrededor no sólo está en los medios de
comunicación tradicionales también están
las redes sociales no en vano todos los
medios de comunicación tienen páginas en
sus redes sociales para que la gente los
siga entonces es través de esta gente
que yo conozco de quiénes están en mi
facebook en mi instagram en mi twitter y
en mis chats de whatsapp o de telegram
que yo también me informa lo que sucede
y más allá yo no voy a estar pensando
que alguien me va a desinformar y que
puede suceder que estas personas que
están en nuestras redes sociales nuestra
mejor amiga o mejor amigo esta figura de
autoridad del barrio la maestra de la
escuela esas personas en quienes
confiamos pueden ser portadores
asintomáticos de la desinformación y con
las mejores intenciones del mundo
infectarnos a nosotros que nosotros nos
enfermemos de infodema y que podamos
meterle el virus a más personas y si
vieran que a veces resulta agotador para
uno como trabajador en primera línea de
esta pandemia el tener que pasar horas y
días estudiando un tema entrevistar a
cuatro o cinco especialistas poder
traducir toda esa información técnica en
un lenguaje amigable para llegarle a las
personas y que después el meme de las
jac de la pgje a chuchita o el tío pérez
egipto vaya a tener muchísimo mayor
difusión que algo y es algo que no está
comprobado nada tiene de malo en hacerle
caso a nuestros tíos amigos o allegados
el punto es saber y ser conscientes de
que cualquiera de nosotros puede ser
portador de este virus de la
desinformación y enfermar a gente de
infodema y por eso mismo tenemos que
tener más cuidado
un estudio del centro internacional de
periodismo encontró que 2 de cada 3
informaciones falsas sobre la pandemia
se daban a través de la red social waste
de facebook y sólo un 35 por ciento a
través de whatsapp pero en costa rica la
cosa es diferente nuestro país según el
latinobarómetro es de los países que más
utiliza whatsapp como mensajería y
entonces es uno de los canales por los
cuales la desinformación viaja más y
viaja más rápido de hecho ya hay dos
estudios del instituto de
investigaciones psicológicas de la
universidad de costa rica que ha
explorado este fenómeno el primero que
es este que tenemos aquí habla acerca de
la desinformación sobre la pandemia en
general sobre la coidh 19 y decía que
las personas residentes en costas y de
baja escolaridad tendían más a creerse
estas informaciones ya compartirlas un
segundo estudio que estaba versado en la
da una contra lakovic 19 hablaba de que
también las personas de baja escolaridad
pero quienes tienen un pensamiento con
ser y ojo esto no está ligado ni a
partidos políticos ni a ningún tipo de
ideología espiritual o manejo de fe
tendían a creer y a compartir más este
tipo de contenidos de desinformación
pero no todo es malo vieran que tengo
grandes aliados en esta primera línea y
esos grandes aliados son profesionales
de la salud que ha incursionado en
comunicar y realmente lo hacen bien
algunos como la doctora maría luisa
ávila ya lo hacía desde la pandemia del
h1n1
pero también está cristian marín miller
el virólogo quien anteriormente estuvo
incursionando en temas de cáncer de
páncreas y ya con la pandemia de coi 19
vino a reforzar la educación en temas de
salud
o la viróloga eugenia corrales aguilar
que es una de las personas con quien yo
más hablo cuando necesito guía en los
temas complejos e incluso hay gente que
lo hace de forma anónima en facebook
como el cirujano odioso
también están en twitter el intensivista
leonardo chacón o el infectólogo saúl
quirós cárdenas o también la médico
tatiana blandón todos ellos han sido
grandes aliados míos y puedo decir que
con todos ellos e interactuado y los he
entrevistado a todos salvo al cirujano
odioso que confieso no sé quién es y
tengo una curiosidad bárbara de saber
quién es pero más allá de lo que me
puedan ayudar a mí en mi trabajo cada
uno de ellos tiene plataformas en sus
redes sociales en las que educan ellos
mismos se han convertido en divulgadores
en pro de la salud de las personas
qué va a pasar después de ahora llegamos
a un este terreno álgido porque viene
campaña política y la desinformación
este virus va a tender a mutar si hay
nuevas variantes del sars cap 2 las
habrá de la desinformación y en campaña
política va a crear nuevas variantes
también y no creo que existe un
candidato político que no vaya a ser
víctima de la info de mya y si mucha de
la información nada con un futuro evento
al manejo de la pandemia en su gobierno
pero para no sonar como muy desesperanza
sobre lo que va a pasar en un futuro les
voy a dar por lo menos mis consejos para
no caer en ser portadores de este virus
enfermarnos y contagiar a alguien más
son por así decirlo mis tips de
periodista entrevisté a cada una de las
informaciones que les llegan para ver si
son desinformación es y cómo se hace
esto pregunten lo primero donde donde
vieron esto les está llegando un
pantalla nada más o es una dirección de
internet a la que usted le pueden dar
clic en ingresar si es lo primero
desconfíen siendo segundo pónganse a ver
de dónde sale esa dirección es un blog
es un medio de comunicación serio dónde
punto 2 y número 2 es quien quien
escribe primero en eso tiene un autor
fíjense en quien escribe si es un medio
de comunicación y ustedes ven que no
viene firmado por alguien desconfíen un
periodista no solo firma para vean qué
bonito que escribían que carga que soy
un periodista que firma le pone el pecho
a las balas y dice si hay algo
incorrecto aquí yo soy responsable y
fíjese también quienes vienen
mencionados si son doctores médicos
virólogos especialistas en salud
realmente existen hágales un google
rápido a ver quiénes están ahí
víctima número 3 que que se dice del
virus se oye muy raro hay cosas que se
dicen parecidas de esto hablando de
pandemia de cualquier otra cosa busquen
el tema y vean si hay otras cosas
similares que están diciendo o si esto
es completamente aparte
tip número 4 cuando ya para ir cerrando
este es el penúltimo fíjense en la fecha
la fecha es trascendental en algo que
viaja tan rápido como la pandemia no
necesariamente lo que se escribió el año
pasado es cierto hoy estamos conociendo
esto tan rápido que fíjense si hay cosas
posteriores que digan lo mismo o no
porque en esto la fecha puede estar
desactualizada muy rápido y algo que se
dijo hace 34 meses no puede ser cierto
puede no ser cierto hoy
punto número cinco está mitin número
cinco
el por qué y este porque no se lo
pregunten como entrevista a lo que les
llega pregúntenselo ustedes mismos
porque voy a compartir esto porque se lo
voy a pasar a más personas
si es porque ya yo hice mi pre
entrevista y las otras cuatro preguntas
fueron este concretadas con éxito y yo
veo que todo eso es cierto si realmente
va a ser necesario porque voy a
construir información y más bien voy a
esto hacer una vacuna para la gente de
lo contrario no compartan nada que no
pase las otras cuatro preguntas porque
eso sí es el virus
para finalizar es eso aunque no seamos
profesionales en comunicación o en salud
todos podemos portar el virus de la
desinformación y todos podemos contagiar
a alguien que enferme con info demia
pero también todos podemos ser
portadores de la vacuna y prevenir la
enfermedad muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]